hey how's it going guys comic-con is in
full effect
but Saturday a lot is happening
including the Aquaman trailer so be sure
to subscribe to my channel so you can
stay up to date on everything that's
happening and so you can get it first so
recently we have received a lot of
information regarding the Joker origin
story that is coming out we have an
official title for it an official
release date and we have a plot but the
craziest thing out of all of these is we
actually have a name for the Joker and
we'll be talking about all of these
throughout this video there are a lot of
things to be excited for about this
movie for one thing Martin Scorsese is
producing it and his movies are awesome
and another thing is this is a
standalone Joker origin movie and what I
mean by that is that this is a
completely different Joker movie than
we've ever seen before and this movie is
completely removed from the DC EU it's
actually set in the early 1980s in
Gotham City of course and this is how
it's described it's an exploration of a
man disregarded by society that is not
only a gritty character study but also a
broader cautionary tale so it's going to
be all about the Joker it's a joker
origin movie so it's about the Joker
which is why it has simply been titled
Joker so there you have it the official
title is Joker and with that official
title came the official release date of
October 4th 2019 so here's where his
name and the plot come in according to
that hashtag show the Joker will start
the movie off as Arthur Fleck apparently
Arthur Fleck returns home with his aging
mother penny to Gotham City this is
where he'll meet Sophie Dumont who is a
single mother and will be his love
interest in the movie but here's where
things get really interesting the site
reveals that flex mother was very
attractive in her youth and that she's
obsessed
her former employer and her former
employer is speculated to be Thomas
Wayne Bruce Wayne's father not only is
it speculated that her former employer
could be Thomas Wayne it's also
speculated that Arthur Fleck could be
Thomas Waynes bastard son if this turns
out to be true that would mean the Joker
and Batman are half-brothers that would
put a ridiculously crazy twist on the
already crazy relationship that the
Joker and Batman have now this specific
part about author Fleck being the
bastard son of Thomas Wayne is just
theory right now but it is something
that I definitely like to see happen in
this Joker origin movie so there you
have it the official title for the Joker
origin movie called Joker the official
release date October 4th 2019 the name
of the Joker
Arthur Fleck the plot of him being in
Gotham with his mother who is obsessed
with her former employer the love
interest that the Joker will have was
Sophie du monde and the theory that the
Joker could be Thomas Waynes bastard son
which would make him and Batman half
brothers so there is all of the
information that we have on Joker so far
what do you all think of the new Joker
origin movie that's coming out next year
let me hear from you in the comments
below be sure to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on Joker and everything
happening this weekend at Comic Con
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof